alicia is in
oakland california hi alicia how can we
help
hey dave thanks for having me um i
i was calling to get some advice from
you i have an idea
of what i should do but it's always good
to call uncle dave
okay so
so my husband and his mom purchased
an apartment condo in 2008
they paid it off december 2018
so they were ahead on a 30-year mortgage
loan
to down to a 10-year essentially um
essentially the dilemma is whether or
not to sell it
or lease it when the time comes for us
to move up in-house you're living
right so we he owns it we're living in
it
technically there's no mortgage but my
husband made an agreement with his mom
at the very beginning to pay her back as
soon as
the mortgage was paid off so he pays
about
her um right correct
okay how much does he owe her to buy her
out
i'm assuming she she says she put in
extra money after her contributions
of money down in the beginning she put
down 90
he put down 10. she says she's
put forward extra i'm assuming it's
around 100.
total so yeah exactly
and what's the condo worth
remodeled it'll be worth about 500.
who's remodeling it we'll remodel it by
the end of next year
okay so if you sold a 500 000
condo and you owed mom 100 to buy out
her part
you would put 400 in your pocket right
essentially at this moment were
by the end of december of this year we
would have paid her 24
000. oh okay so only only 75 000 left
okay
right so she
her mind in the very beginning of
helping him
co-sign was to at
some point lease it out and use that
money
as essentially a secondary income
for both of them but it's a
not that practical because
our thought is as husband and wife we
will
sell it and then we'll use that money to
put down
well over 20 for our new house yeah
right so she co-signed okay so either
you're going to buy her out
by paying it off and by selling it right
right and that's going to give her the
100 or the 75 remaining
or she's going to write you a check for
the difference in 575
which would be 400 and a quarter right
she doesn't see it like that though
right
i'm here i think she wants to force him
to stay in the deal
right and she's right yeah well
even if that did happen how would we
coordinate
it's dumb don't do it i know
i'm just trying to understand how to
approach her you're not
you're the wicked stepdaughter
well we actually have a great
relationship yeah but you're still the
step
you're still the daughter-in-law you
don't get to approach anything your
husband grows a backbone and says mom
i'm not staying in a rental property
with you i'm selling it
you can take this money and go buy you
another rental property if you want
uh which is 75 000 or whatever you want
to do but i'm not going to stay in a
rental property
no right yeah it doesn't work for us the
idea of a rental property
but it's just not practical right now
yeah and but
you don't want to be in the deal with
her i mean nothing against her but like
no yeah i agree you all do your own
thing owing people money i i hate it
yeah
the whole thing's uh it's it's started
with good intentions it's quickly
getting twisted
yeah so but let me tell you from
just life experience you keep your mouth
shut
no okay your husband has to deal with
his mommy
yeah you don't deal with his mommy he
has to deal with his mommy
okay this is the kind of crap that will
visit you two decades later
yeah if you open your mouth if this is
your fault
in her mind this is a problem
he needs to square his shoulders be a
big boy
and deal with mommy he can be kind and
sweet i'm being sarcastic but he should
be nice
he should honor her mom i really
appreciate this but uh
you know me and alicia we're gonna buy a
house and we're gonna use this that
we're going to use this huge stinking
equity
and thank you for getting me into this
deal because it really did work out and
i love you
and we're going to sell it and i'm going
to write you a check for that other 75
if i haven't written it even before then
matter of fact you ought to buy her out
as soon as possible and that ends the
discussion
i got a quick question alicia are you
and your husband on the same page i
don't want to just assume that are you
and your husband on the same page with
this okay
that will make it easier then if he and
her wanted this deal and you and him
aren't on the same page that would be
different
so that's great then yeah just like dave
said like this is his conversation to
have
yeah yeah but here's the problem okay he
wants
every little boy wants his mommy to be
happy
and mommy mommy may not be happy when
this is done
they they they've had a history of a
rocky relationship
so it's definitely uh
a sensitive subject yeah which is why we
don't do these deals to start with but
now here we are
so is this is this is is your husband
um you know is he willing to lean into
conflict have confrontation or is that
something that he just would rather just
you know certain personalities types
really like to avoid conflict
where does her husband kind of follow
him oh my god no one's
you pick a fight just because you're
bored sometimes alicia
does your husband feel about this
no i would say he's half and half okay
she's had arguments with her before
about
her opinion yeah in in trying to control
his life
yeah and what not i it's interesting
i i definitely can communicate better
with her
than him and her until there's conflict
right but she's
she's she's always had good intentions
you know she has good intentions she's
just
she's just a control from
mommies love to tell their little boys
what to do and it doesn't matter how old
they get
yeah it's just there's a different
dynamic there
my wife can have a discussion that is
perfectly normal with my daughters
and yet she wants to tell my son what to
do and he just looks at her mom i love
you
no
because he's like a man and everything
and so um yeah
yeah no he's got good boundaries no
and uh but here's the thing here's what
only thing i would coach him to do
because of all the all the data we have
from talking to you for the last few
minutes is
i've been real sarcastic and bombastic
which is my style okay
but were i in his shoes i would approach
this very humbly
very low tone and octave
drop your oc drop your voice an octave
uh
and just be very kind
unbelievably strong
and gentle and grateful
lots of gratitude and honor is due her
she made him four hundred thousand
dollars it's going to help your future
and i would bow to that i would say
thank you mom
you have done so many good and wonderful
things
and the intent of us getting into this
has resulted in this wonderful blessing
to us
thank you so much for that thank you for
thinking of me
all those years ago when we did this
deal and i just want to tell you no
matter
whether you understand or whether you
don't we're we're going to sell it
and i just want you to know how grateful
i am and thankful
and it's not like he's asking her
opinion he's not asking he's not taking
a poll
he's just gonna tell her what he's doing
but with a smile and gentleness
and strength meekness is not weakness
it's power under control
and you're in the driver's seat here